now that the station sponsors have all
identified themselves we pause briefly
for the show next Awards well I know
that dedicated sensitive creative
artists the writer without whom this
other introduction would not have been
written to present the Writing Awards
here's the very exciting miss Lee Remick
and mr. Jack Lemmon who does nothing for
me at all
he's Baba funny Jack you were wondering
too let's read the nominations for the
best screenplay based on material from
another medium the nominees are
George Axelrod Breakfast at Tiffany's
Carl Foreman the Guns of Navarone Sidney
Carol and Robert rossen The Hustler
happy man judgment at Nuremberg Ernest
layman West Side Story and the winner is
the winner is Abbey man
a few years ago I retired to a room on
58th Street in New York and I retired
there with some legal records in the
Third Reich and I went there because I
believe that a writer who's worth his
salt at all there's an obligation not
only to entertain but to comment on the
world in which he lives
no need a comment maybe but to maybe
have a shot at me shaping that world
it's a long way from that room to this
hall and I couldn't accept this without
without mentioning a couple of a lines I
picked up on the way one of course is my
brilliant mentor Stanley Kramer a man of
courage talent and a man of his word and
probably the most gifted cast the writer
ever had in picture to say thanks to you
Spence Burt
Judy dick Marlene max I tell you I I
consider this from the Academy to be a
trust and I promise you this I won't
abuse it
Jack I have a confession to make I've
always wanted to write a movie no he's
nothing a little blank paper a
typewriter and the Bible anyway that
doesn't apply to this next group
nominated for the best story and
screenplay written directly for the
screen our story and screenplay by
Valentin you Joe and Grigory to cry for
Ballad of a soldier story and screenplay
by Sergio Amadeu Diego Fabri an interim
Anton Oliver general Oliveira story
screenplay by Federico Fellini - Jochen
le any of lion-o and Brunello Rhonda
Paula Dolce Vita story and screenplay by
Stanley Shapiro
and Paul Henning for lover comeback
story and screenplay by William Inge for
splendour in the grass you read the
winner judge yeah thanks a lot
the winner is William Inge for splendor
in the grass
you never know how you're going to feel
about this sort of thing until it
happens a very movie I'm very grateful
to Elia Kazan to marvelous cast and once
crew